Çeviri: İnci Arslan
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Bronnie Ware bir hemşire.
Ölüm döşeğindeki hastaların
son haftalarına refakat ediyor.
Dolayısıyla onları psikolojilerini
çok iyi biliyor
ve "Top Five Regrets of Dying" diye
bir kitap yazmış.
Bütün deneyimlerini topladığı.
Ölüm döşeğindeki hastaların
tamamına yakını
en çok şu beş şey hakkında
pişmanlık duyuyor.
Tahmin edersiniz hepsi
"keşke" ile başlıyor.
"Keşke kendi hayatımı
yaşama cesareti gösterebilseydim."
"Keşke o kadar çok çalışmasaydım."
"Keşke duygularımı açıklama cesareti
gösterebilseydim."
"Keşke arkadaşlarımla
daha fazla görüşseydim."
"Keşke daha mutlu olmama izin verseydim."
Dikkat edin buradakilerin hiçbiri maddiyat
ya da parayla alakalı olan şeyler değil.
Hepsi, özellikle en üstteki,
"başkalarının değil kendi hayatımı
yaşayabilme cesareti gösterebilseydim."
En sondaki de özellikle
"Daha mutlu olmama izin verseydim."
Çünkü insanlar ölüm döşeğinde
yaptıklarından veya hatalarından değil,
yapabileceği hâlde yapmadıklarından dolayı
pişmanlık duyuyorlar.
Önemli olan çünkü
hayatı uzun değil iyi yaşamak.
Yaklaşık on dört yıl önce
kurumsal hayatın,
on altı yıllık profesyonel hayatın
on ikinci, on üçüncü yıllarındayım.
Artık bir şeylerin ufak ufak
dank etmeye başladığı zamanlar.
İyi okullarda okumuşsunuz,
iyi şirketlerde başlamışsınız,
Procter & Gamble gibi.
Daha sonra uluslararası bir
reklam ajansında, Alice/BBDO'da,
uzunca bir dönem var.
Beş sene kadar.
Daha sonra Nissan Otomotiv,
daha sonra Komili,
daha sonra Nicholson International
diye bir head hunter (kafa avcısı)
ve en son da Turkcell.
Her bir geçiş daha büyük sorumluluklarla
daha büyük yetkilerle olmuş.
Yani daha da fazla para kazanmaya
başlamışız.
Aldığımız sorumluluklar, yetkiler
büyüdükçe masalar büyümeye başlamış.
Örneğin eskiden ortalarda otururken
daha sonra cam kenarına doğru
oturmaya başlamışız.
Daha sonra cam kenarındaki masamız
bir pozisyon atladığımız için
on santim büyümüş.
Hatta daha sonra
on santim daha büyümüş
veya daha sonra odalar
verilmeye başlanıyor.
Sekreterler, asistanlar, arabalar,
arabaların markası değişmeye başlıyor.
Üst modellere geçiyorsunuz.
Yani kısacası bu hayatta
eğer işinizi düzgün yapıyorsanız,
dürüstseniz, çalıp çırpmıyorsanız,
işe vaktinde gidip geliyorsanız,
oturmanız, kalkmanız, kıyafetiniz
düzgünse ve sizden beklenilen işi
en azından minimum seviyede
yapıyorsanız,
normal şartlarda dışarıdan bir etken
olmadığı sürece
o iş yerinde çalışmaya devam edersiniz.
Fakat ne zaman ki pozisyonları atladıkça
size öyle bir ortam
sunulmaya başlanıyor ki,
gerçekten kendinizi bir bok
zannetmeye başlıyorsunuz.
Öyle zannetmeniz isteniyor zaten.
Çünkü şirketler bütün
eğitim programlarıyla
çırpınıyorlar sizi
değerli hissettirmek için.
Fakat yapacak bir şeyleri yok çünkü
ne yapabilir? Eğitime gönderebilir,
belki bir tatile gönderebilir,
belki bir performans değerlendirmesinde
bir çıt daha fazla puan verip
daha fazla para almanızı sağlayabilir.
Dikkat edin hepsi öyle veya böyle
bir şekilde maddiyatla alakalı.
Fakat biz insanların
en çok istediği şey esasında
samimiyetle, gerçek anlamda
insan yerine konulmak.
Gözlerimizin içine bakıldığında
"Benim için değerlisin.
Yaptıklarından çok bu insan olduğun için
sen olduğun için bu şirkette çalışıyorsun"
Oysa verilen mesajlar "Çok değerlisin.
ama yarın o şirketten çıktığın zaman
hiçbir şey değişmez şirkette."
Her şey geriye döner.
Dikkat edin,
okul zamanlarından itibaren
hep biz başkalarının gözünde
adam olmak üzere başlıyoruz.
Annelerimizin, babalarımızın,
hocalarımızın.
İyi not alacağız ki onların gözünde,
hocalarımızın gözünde adam olalım.
Çok fazla yaramazlık yapmayacağız veya
iyi not alacağız,
annemizin babamızın gözünde adam olalım.
Derslerimiz iyi olsun,
üniversite sınavını kazanalım,
daha sonra bir işe girelim.
Bu sefer patronumuzun gözünde
adam olalım.
Evlenirsek o zaman eşimizin,
çocuklarımız olursa çocuklarımızın.
Dikkat edin her dönem neredeyse hep
başkalarının gözünde adam olmak.
Öncelikle hep başkalarını mutlu etmek
üzerine kurgulu bir hayat yaşıyoruz.
Ta ki belli bir şeyleri yaşadıktan,
belli evreleri geçirdikten sonra
insan belki de artık
kendine bakmaya başlıyor
ve umarım çok geç olmadan.
Biraz önce bahsettiğim o kurumsal hayat,
biz sadece şirketlerde maruz kaldığımız
duygusal terapilerin dışında
aynı zamanda izlediğimiz filmler, diziler,
reklamlarla, arkadaşlarımızla, çevreyle,
esasında bizler için yaratılan adına da
kimlik denilen hapishanelere konuyor
ve çoğu kez bunun farkında bile olmuyoruz.
Sonra da o kimliğin esiri oluyor
ve mutlu olmanın sadece
bir yoldan ibaret olduğunu unutuyoruz.
Bizler dört duvar ev almak için
on sene boyunca bankaya kredi ödüyoruz.
On senelik ömrümüzün olduğunu
bilmediğimiz hâlde.
Çünkü bize dayatılan gerçek şu:
"Bu işin yaşlılığı da var.
Garanti altına al geleceğini."
Dört duvar hapishanenin geleceği garanti
altına almak olduğu bizlere
default (varsayılan) doğru
olarak veriliyor.
Veya buradaki diğer şeyler.
Bir gün artık kendime
şu soruyu sormaya başladım:
"Tunç, sıkıcı ve rezil
bir hayat yaşıyorsam hak ediyorum."
sıkıcı ve rezil bir hayattan kastım
maddiyat değil.
Az önce söyledim size.
İyi imkânlarla geliyor her şey.
Ama mutluluğun parada olmadığını
fark etmeye başladığımız bir an var.
Çünkü bütün bunlar esasında bizlere
sunduğu konforlu bir uyuşukluk.
Sonra dedim ki "Tunç,
sen yeteri kadar mutsuzsan,
o zaman bu durumu değiştirmek için
her şeyi göze alırsın.
Hatta almakla kalmaz, adım atarsın,
risk alırsın.
Çünkü yeteri kadar mutsuz değilsin.
Sorun, öyle olduğunu sanman."
Ve sonra, 14 yıl kadar önceden
bahsediyorum,
iki ay gibi kısa bir süre içerisine
şu olaylar sığdı.
Dört tane dramatik olay sığdı:
Anne vefat etti, anneyle aramızda
aşk vardı.
İkincisi çok severek evlendiğim
ve severek de boşandığım,
hâlâ da çok saygı duyduğum
eşimden ayrıldım.
On yıl boyunca bizimle birlikte uyuyan
köpeğimiz vefat etti.
Ve iş hayatımda şirkette
çok ciddi sıkıntıların, değişimlerin
olduğu bir dönemdi.
Bu dördü birden iki aylık süreye sığınca
dedim "Tunç, bir şeyler oluyor.
Sana burada bir mesaj var."
Sonra anneyi toprağa verirken
şu soruyu sordum kendime:
"İki yıllık ömrünün kaldığını bilsen bugün
yaptıklarını yapmaya devam eder misin?"
Kendime, sevdiklerime ve yapmaktan
haz aldığım şeylere vakit ayırmak yerine
para uğruna, güç uğruna, kariyer uğruna
yaptıklarımı yapmaya devam eder miyim?
Veya ayıp olmasın diye
görüştüğüm insanlarla görüşmeye,
gittiğim yerlere gitmeye, toplantılara,
normal şartlarda selam vermeyeceğim
insanları seviyormuş gibi yapmaya,
yani -mış gibi yapmaya
devam eder miydim?
Tabii ki bu soruların hepsinin cevabı
hayır oldu.
İnsanlar enteresan, hiç ölmeyecek gibi
yaşıyorlar, yaşıyoruz.
Ancak en büyük korkumuz da ölüm.
En büyük korkumuz ölüm olduğu için de
bu sefer adım atmıyoruz,
risk almıyoruz.
Krishnamurti der ki: "Sizce yere düşen
bir yaprak ölümden korkar mı?
Bir kuşun ölümden korkarak
yaşadığını düşünebilir misiniz?
Kuş ne zaman gelirse
o zaman tanışır ölümle.
Ama ölümden endişe duymaz.
Böcekleri yakalaması, yuva yapması,
şakıması, tadını çıkara çıkara uçmasıyla,
yani daha çok yaşamakla ilgilenir.
Kuşların kanatlarını çırpmadan, sadece
rüzgarda gökyüzünde süzülüşlerini
izlediniz mi hiç? Ne kadar ebedi
bir zevk içinde görünürler.
Ölümden endişe duymazlar.
Ölüm gelirse problem değil,
yok olurlar. Sonrasında ne olacağıyla
ilgili bir endişeleri yoktur.
Bir andan diğerine doğru yaşarlar.
Biz insanoğlu ise, bizler her zaman
ölümden endişe ederiz.
Çünkü biz, yaşamıyoruz.
Sorun bu. Biz ölüyoruz.
Peki, böyle gelmiş tamam da,
böyle mi gitmek zorunda?
Sahi, neden bir ömre
birden çok hayat sığmasın ki?"
İşte bu sorulardı
beni tekrar kendime getiren.
Evet bizlere bir takım kartlar
dağıtılıyor doğru.
Hangi zaman diliminde, hangi anne babadan
doğacağımızı bilmiyoruz.
Hangi memlekette, hangi dili
ilk öğreneceğimizi de bilmiyoruz.
Seçemediğimiz şeyler bunlar.
Ancak daha sonra,
kartlar bizim elimize dağıtıldıktan sonra,
en azından belli bir yetişkinliğe
geldikten sonra,
bu kartları hangi masalarda,
hangi zamanlarda, kimlerle
oynayacağımız esasında bizlerin kararı.
Hangi kartı ne zaman atacağımız,
hangi kartı ne zaman alacağımız
bizlerin kararı.
Çünkü hayat bizim elimizde esasında.
Ama, en başında da konuşmuştuk,
biz başkalarının hayatını
yaşamaya odaklandırılmışız.
Çünkü hep başkaları bizim adımıza
mutluluğun tarifini yapar halde.
Nereye geldi durum?
Bütün bu yaşanılanlar bana dedi ki:
"Kimse esasında beni
hayal kırıklığına uğratmadı.
Benim en büyük hayal kırıklığım
kendi zafer tanımımdı."
Her gece yattığımda yeni güne
uyanmadan önce şu soruyu
sorar hâldeyim artık,
bunu hâlâ devam ettiriyorum:
"Yarın sabah uyanabilecek miyim?"
Ve yarın sabah uyandığım zaman "Ne kadar
güzel bu sabah da uyandın artık." diyorum.
Yaşananlar basitleştikçe zihnimde,
o zaman olayları da daha basit görmeye
başlıyorum ve daha basit,
daha sade yaşamaya başlıyorum.
Başka insanların gözünde basit görünmek de
benim gözümde bir iltifat oluyor.
Hâlâ zaman zaman oluyor,
ne zaman kendimi bir bok sansam
dört buçuk milyarlık dünyanın
doksan dakikalık bir filmi çekilse
bir saniyelik rolüm olmayacağını
hatırlatıyorum kendime.
Daralmam geçiyor.
Veya kararsız anlarımda
kendime şunu soruyorum:
"Tunç iki yıllık ömrün kalsa
hangisini seçersin?"
Karar hemen geliyor arkasından.
Veya çok kızgın anlarımda,
trafikte vesaire:
"Tunç her neyse şuan kızdığın, buna iki
gün sonra da aynı şekilde kızacak mısın?"
Hayır kızmayacağım.
O zaman niye o iki günü
satın almıyorsun?
Şikayet eden ve mutsuz kişilerden
uzaklaşmaya başladım.
Çünkü çok sıkıcılar hepsi.
Hayattaki sıçışlarımla dalga geçtikçe
onları tekrar etmediğimi fark ediyorum.
Ama ciddiye aldıklarımsa
hiç yakamı bırakmıyor.
Ve hiç kimseden bir şey
beklememeyi öğreniyorum.
Kolay bir şey değil.
Ama daha zoru
insanın esasında kendinden de
çok fazla bir şey beklememesi.
Kuş misali Krishnamurti'nin söylediği...
Çok hayal kuruyorum. Sayıca
fazla olunca bir tanesi gerçek oluyor.
Ve her gün en az birine, bir kişiye
seni seviyorum diyorum.
Dedikçe daha çok seviyorum.
Çünkü sevdiklerime verebileceğim
en değerli hediye
esasında daha mutlu bir ben.
Bir de içimdeki veleti daha çok dinliyorum
Örneğin bir gün Kaş'tayız. Yanımda
bir arkadaşım var, şapkalı.
Bir şeyler çiziyor. Kaptım şapkasını Mavi
Bar'ın karşısındayız Kaş'ı bilenler için.
Orda hadi dedim "gel dilencilik yapıyoruz"
Önümüzde şapka, insanlar geçiyorlar.
"Bak" diyorum "Hadi çocuk çiziyor,
atsana bir lira."
"Abi manyak mısın sen" diyor.
Başka bir tanesi geçiyor yirmi beş
kuruş atıyor, bir tanesi on kuruş atıyor.
Kimisi şey gözlerle bakıyor:
"Ne yapıyorsunuz siz?"
Kimisi manyak keyif alıyor,
hatta yanımıza gelip oturanlar var.
Hatta bize akıl verenler var "Abi şöyle
yapsanız daha çok para toplarsınız." gibi.
Kâğıt para verenler var,
"Vallahi bozuk param olsa verecektim."
"Ver abi sen kağıdı biz bozarız" dedik.
Hakikaten kağıt para verip
bozduklarımız oldu.
Müthiş vakit geçirdik iki saat boyunca.
Elli lira da para topladık.
Fakat bundan daha enteresan olan şuydu:
Mavi Bar'da oturan 55-60 yaşlarında
bir abi masadan kalktı bize doğru geldi,
elini de cüzdanına doğru atıp.
Emre'ye vurdum böyle:
"Oğlum Emre zengin olduk!"
Hakikaten adam cüzdanı çıkardı,
kağıt para verdi on lira.
En büyük aldığımız kağıt para da
oydu zaten.
"Abim" dedim yumruklaştık,
"Çok teşekkür ederim."
"Biraz oturabilir miyim yanınıza?" dedi.
"Tabi ki!" dedim.
"Ben seni oturduğum sandalyeden
izliyorum dakikalardır." dedi.
"Nasıl bu kadar içten mutlu olabiliyorsun?
Nasıl bu kadar çok gülümsüyorsun?
Nasıl bu kadar çok eğlenebiliyorsun?"
Abi dedim "Etraftaki güzellikleri görmemek
somurtmak zor olan. "Sen niye" dedim
"Orada tek başına oturuyorsun?"
"Esasında" dedi "Ben kızımla geldim.
Almanya'daydım, kızım şu an otelde."
"Abi" dedim "Kızın niye otelde onun cevabı
herhalde sende olmak zorunda."
Sustu.
"Ben esasında" dedi "Büyük bir holdingin
sahibinin oğluyum.
Sadece kendimin değil kendi evlatlarımın
torunlarının da geleceklerini
garanti altına alacak kadar da servetimiz
var ama Tunç ben senin kadar mutlu değilim
"Abi" dedim "Tanımında bile para var.
Evet böyle gidersen mutlu olmazsın.
Basit bak abi hayata."
Kartını verdi "Ne zaman bir şeye
ihtiyacın olursa ara beni Tunç." dedi.
Abi dedim "Ben seni sağlığını sormak için
ararım"Bir şey yapalım anlamında söylüyor.
Abinin bu şeyi bile esasında ne kadar
çok şey öğretiyor bize.
İçimdeki veleti dinlediğim
başka bir olay mesela
fikir atölyesinde başlattığımız
faili meçhul kıyak oyunu.
Bu bir tane kart. Tanımadığımız insanlara
bu kartı yapmış olduğumuz
güzellikle beraber veriyoruz.
Okuduğunuz bir kitap olabilir,
seyrettiğiniz bir dvd olabilir veya
yoldan koparttığınız bir papatyaya
bu kartı ataçlıyorsunuz.
Tıpkı sizin çantalarınıza şuan
ismini bilmediğiniz, TED konferanslarına
çok inanan çok seven bir iş adamının
sizlere faili meçhul kıyak yaptığı gibi...
Veya beni reddettin.
Sürekli barlara gidiyorum sap
arkadaşlarımla, bodyguardlar almıyor.
Yandakine gidiyoruz almıyor.
Ve yanımızda öyle insanlar var ki,
"Sen benim kim olduğumu
biliyor musun?" diyor.
Ne bok olursan ol adam almıyor işte seni.
Siniri bozuluyor insanın.
Ondan sonra dedim ki "Bir şey yapalım
reddetmeyi eğlenceli hâle getirelim."
Hayatta sürekli biz de birilerine hayır
diyoruz ve bize de hayır denilmesi kadar
doğal bir şey yok. Gittiniz bir barda
birine bir şeyler ısmarladınız,
kabul etmedi, gidin kartınızı verin
beni reddettin diyin.
Çünkü insanlar önce
kendi hayatlarının devrimcisi olmalı.
Bundan sonraki mottom,
eğer becerebilirsem,
Şu gördüğünüz Volkswagen'i aldım,
'79 model.Şuan yaptırıyorum onu.
Elimdeki arabayı satıp bunu aldım.
Tek arabam bu olacak.
"Yaz, gez ve fotoğraf çek."
Becerebilirsem şuan
kendi hayatımın devrimciliğini
bu yönde yapmaya çalışıyorum.
Sağlıklıyız, özgürüz, sevebiliyoruz,
hayal ediyoruz. O zaman bu zamana.
Hepinizi yürekten kucaklıyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.